[Music]
all right we're going to go into your
very first
feature film credit which is it's a big
one with with quite the ensemble and
you're working with james brooks
directing
actually maybe i'll go specifically with
working with him as a director because
correct me if i'm wrong but i believe
he's the kind of director who likes to
find
moments on set on the spot so what was
it about
you know his process and approach to the
work that maybe is really stuck with you
i mean with mr brooks
we were gonna do it until he felt he had
it
all right now again you know that was my
first um
feature film so i didn't have a clue
about a lot of things
and you know once we got up in to take
50 something i'm just thinking as a
young
actor who's just out of school like
okay this is what it is you have to have
this kind of stamina this is one scene
take 50 something and i'm like okay then
i look at other people and they're like
this is not normal i said oh okay you
know i don't know
i didn't know a lot of things and
um it was wonderful to work with reese
i've been a fan of hers
since i you know way back in the day not
way back you know she's a
young lady she is um but just such a
huge fan of hers and to be able to work
alongside her in my first feature
film i remember this one moment where we
were on the national mall
so i'm in bc i got to travel here to
work
it's me and rhys and where our
characters are racing
and so mr brooks is on i don't know like
an atv or something with the camera
and they're going alongside us in the
script it says
my character wins so again my first time
really on camera like this so they say
action i'm like i gotta
i gotta do well i gotta bring it he says
action i take off oh i like
yes i guess all i hear behind me stop
god god god i'm like oh my gosh i look
back reese stopped running she comes up
she says
you can't run past the camera honey
i was like oh oh oh okay
mr brooks was like take it again take it
again but he was a lovely lovely man
um it's so sweet so sweet but i yeah i
told you all of that you did not ask for
all of that but yeah
you